bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france elle les mesures annoncées hier
sont elles suffisantes pour aider les
acteurs du monde de la nuit à traverser
cette crise vous savez la situation est
tellement difficile que safari dame est
suffisant il ya au moins un but pour
être tout à fait cohérent c'est la
première fois qu'on a un geste de cette
importance qui furent un direction des
discothèques et je veux tout d'abord le
salut 1,16 de 50 millions pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur
c'est à peu près 20% du nos frais fixes
de tout le secteur qui sont de 200 250
millions donc c'est quand même quelque
chose qui est très appréciable sachant
que nous avons pas ailleurs le chômage
partiel
nous avons par ailleurs les prêts
garantis par l'état c'est à 45000 euros
sepa 15000 euros tout simple c'est que
quarante cinq mille euros c'est quinze
mille euros en juin quinze mille euros
en juillet quinze mille euros en août
dit s'ajoute au fonds de soutien initial
de 1500 euros par mois et avec une
clause de revoyure à la fin du mois
d'août parce que nous ne savons pas ce
qui va venir des dix spots et au mois de
septembre nous a laissé c'est bien ça le
grand drame alors suffisant oui sauf
pour les très très gros les très gros
ont des frais qui sont aux alentours de
40 à 60 mille euros par mois donc pensez
bien que 15000 rossa lapierre juste et
tout mon travail de syndicaliste
responsable a consisté à faire
comprendre à ces gros que pour qu'ils
prennent sur eux qui ne licencient
surtout pas et qui préservent leurs
outils travail ne dépose pas le bilan
tant pis il faut qu'ils passent cet
effort là et j'espère de tout mon coeur
qu'on pourrait ouvrir à la rentrée de
septembre
cela fait près de 80 ans maintenant que
les discothèques eux sont fermées est ce
que vous craignez des fermetures
massives d'établissement est ce que
c'est déjà le cas ce que vous avez
quelques chiffres à nous donner je peux
vous donner des chiffres très précis
malheureusement actuellement nous avons
300 établissements envisagent de déposer
le client bilan il y en a 38 qui l'ont
déjà fait et ça représente globalement 7
à 8000 personnes qui risquent de se
retrouver m'excuserai latry vérité
l'expression sur le capi 7 à 8 personnes
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé sur
la france aéronautique française et par
contre ils sont une aide de cinq
milliards d'euros ce qui peut-être pas
tout à fait comparable
l'enjeu n'est pas non plus le même donc
c'est quand même quelque chose de très
important 8000 personnes en particulier
des jeunes et je veux absolument arrêter
cette hémorragie et je pense qu à fait
ce qu'a fait monsieur alain griset sous
couvert bien entendu de monsieur bruno
le maire notre ministre des finances est
quelque chose de nature à nous aider
puissamment le tout c'est de savoir
jusqu'à quand ça va durer cette
situation d'insécurité
je veux bien qu aucun doute on
renouvelle et qu'on accroissent encore
les aides mais ce n'est pas une solution
vous savez être en respiration
artificielle ont préféré y avait
normalement et naturellement vous
comprenez la nécessité de garder fermées
les discothèques aujourd'hui aux biens
comme certains de vos collègues qu'on a
beaucoup entendu ces derniers jours
cette affaire semaine est ce que vous
réclamez la réouverture des discothèques
est ce que cela vous semble facile de
mettre en pratique les mesures de
distanciation sociale je vais tout à
fait clair moi je n'ai jamais été un
partisan d'un web tu as tout comme les
importants syndicats disent low-tech et
nous avons toujours été partisan de m
l'impératif sécuritaire sans tête
pardon sécurité publique en premier et
la santé de notre pays doit passer avant
tout et on comprend très bien qu'un
effort à faire toutes les cases
population et canet en faire ce que l'on
ne comprend pas par contre c'est
qu'aujourd'hui pour être discothèque y a
qu une condition à remplir c'est de ne
pas être une discothèque et dans tous
les lieux n'importe où les avis oui les
locations chez des particuliers dans les
bars ambiance musicale dans les
restaurants dans les salles de fêtes
partout vous avez des discothèques
le spa près du canal saint-martin je
passe sous le pont david est je parle
pas sur les quais de seine à paris mais
je les indics quand même partout c'est
la danse c'est du grand n'importe quoi
et ça c'est assez difficile d'admettre
non pas par jalousie pas là le problème
le problème c'est que iris qui à voir
sur le plan sanitaire une seconde bac
qui va être dû à cette irresponsabilité
et les premiers qui vont payer pour
cette seconde vague ça va être les
exploitants de discothèques
parce que eux n'auront pas participé à
ces dérives mais vont être les premiers
sanctionnés parce qu'ils vont pas
pouvoir et ouvrir en septembre en
octobre
et ça c'est parfaitement intolérable eu
égard aussi au fait que par rapport à
santé publique
les français sont absolument abasourdi
de voir ce qu'ils voient ils voient tous
ces débordements lors dinis au texan
permet le joue le jeu elle accepte je
l'acceptent
mais on voit bien que ça ne se passe pas
du tout comme ça ailleurs excellent le
laxisme et qu'on laisse faire donc il
faut absolument que des mesures soient
prises pour endiguer tout ça nous avons
des départements je pense au finistère
je pense oh mon client il ya d'autres
départements où messieurs les préfets
ont commencé à prendre des mesures de
sauvegarde
il faut les étendent les ans loin de les
étendre pour une raison simple c'est
qu'il ne faut pas une seconde à il faut
que notre pays retrouve la normalité son
fonctionnement et que les discothèques
puisse un jour reprendre au mois
d'octobre
merci beaucoup pour votre réaction
patrick mal grès je rappelle que vous
êtes président du syndicat national de
ladite des discothèques
merci beaucoup